hello everyone and welcome back to the
fede Grand Prix being played in Hamburg
these this is a game from the
quarterfinals it's Peter Svidler versus
then he'll do both really an exciting
game I'm sure gonna enjoyed it as well
it has a lot of everything and I didn't
end up going to Hamburg I just stayed in
but Pearman for the whole three days you
know enjoying some time with family so
sorry about not going to hamburg and not
being able to meet some of you guys but
you know there's always next time so
that being said let's check out this
very nice game it's a game from the well
two of the classical games have been
wrong then two of the rapid games have
been drawn and this is the first game of
this of the faster rapid game this is
the ten minutes plus ten seconds
increments so let let's check it out
Twitter with the white pieces opens wit
Knight to f3 now we have d5 g3 and the
g6 so the things in an attack of the
ready opening is on the board we have
Busch up to g2 and Bishop to g7 we have
d4 and Knight to f6
dubov is ready to castle and also
settler so Cellular castles do both
castles and here we have Bishop to e3
the the most common move here is just c4
which seems normal but Svidler goes for
Bishop to e3 probably has a surprise
idea now if you're wondering why Bishop
to e3 it's it's a good eye it's a good
question I'm wondering myself probably
to prevent c5 you know black wants to
play c5 at some point c5 Knight 6 it's
normal way to develop so for example if
white play something like before then
you can just play c5 and you get a very
very natural development you don't block
your pawn with the knight on c6 for
example so here Bishop to e3 probably as
a way of computer confusing do both and
may be gaining some time in the opening
but do both probably c6 here is the way
to go
just as you can go c5 c6 is probably
what black would play here it was a
classical game if you if you wanted to
play the best move but the dubov is very
rare
interested in playing the best movie
always plays well
pretty pretty wild ideas so we have h3
and now comes Luke the eight by du Bois
preparing a e5 and since there is no
reason for this Bishop to stay here
there is no c5 in the position swinger
moves the bishop back to f4 and this is
not a new position I mean there's a
player for is a new move but this is not
a new position Bishop to c1 people have
played this you know freeing up some
space for the ee3 move c30 move Knight
to c3 and one move but the move a
swindler plays is a new move in the
position so Bishop to f4 and we have a
completely new game as of move eight so
we nice to h5 DuBose's ok move that
Bishop from f4 that is a nice diagonal
for the bishop also opens up his own
diagonal so Bishop to g5 and now h6
pushing the bishop all the way back we
rushed back the c1 by Sevilla and now
Knight backed Knight back to f6 and now
II five is definitely coming so here a
swindler
could go rush back to afford and do go
would kick the bishop away butcher back
to e3 it didn't black it's already start
some trouble with a move like g4 so
thriller not interested in this ski says
it's time to develop more pieces so
tonight the b2 and now II five hello
case wheeler captures with D captures
only five and now not recapturing
immediately but first night the e4
saying do you want to trade everything
and the trading everything doesn't
really work all that well for white for
example if knife captures pawn
characters and Queen captures you get
rook captures and then as your knight
here is under attack you have to move it
but now this pawn is under attack in
just captured but even better you can go
Knight d4 now this pawn is under attack
this pawn is under attack this point is
under attack and black would adjust
pretty much solve all of all of the
blacks opening problems so here instead
of trading sweater first goes c4 which
makes sense you wanna you always want to
attack the central pawn with with a less
central pawn and now comes Knight
captures on d2 we have Queen captures on
d2 and now D captures on c4 again dubov
offers a trade of Queens
well he's playing black he he doesn't
want anything too crazy yeah you know
next game he gets white and then maybe
he can look for some chances they're
similar of course declines this he wants
to keep some chances alive and here not
winning the pawn right away with knife
captures on e5 but rather Bishop to e6
first defending the c4 pawn there's
always time to capture on e5 so we have
Bishop to e3 filler now continuous
development again it uses this e3
squared to develop the Bishop for this
game developing the e2 pawn doesn't seem
all that all that necessary now we have
Queen to e7 by dubov preparing to bring
the other look into the game and now
rook F the d1 this is always an eternal
question in a lot of chess positions
which rook goes to the open file do you
want to bring the a rock or the F rook
over here if you bring the F rook maybe
you want to push the a4 or a5 maybe the
rook will be useful on the a file or if
you put the a file here maybe maybe
you're interested maybe moving the
knight pushing f4 at some point so here
so Larry decides that the F of the
belongs on the D file and okay we have
rook a to d8 countering White's rook on
the D file and now rook a to C 1 and
here b5 duo is just preparing b4 and
Spiller wants to prevent this if you if
you don't prevent it if you play
something like h4 you get before the
Queen is under attack Queen moves now
Knight captures on e5 and the black is
just well black is just very very
comfortable here so instead Spiller
decides to prevent b4 he plays a three
and now comes Bishop to d5 and it's a
very seemingly a simple move but it's a
deadly move it's just
well if sweedler let's say place
something like a four wants to create
two to two doubled pawns on on the Queen
side then basically the idea behind the
35 is just the trade Bishop captures he
captures you don't want to capture with
the bishop so after Knight captures on
e5 with the bishop on f3 is not under
attack but here better characters
attacking the Queen and after the Queen
moves the night before just looks very
strong and now after this night comes to
d3 it's just a much better position for
black let's say Queen moves Knight d3
now this pawn is under attack the rookie
under attack once you move the rook the
the b-pawn can fall the a four-pound can
fall it's it's just a much better
position for black so here after this
Bishop to d5 moves Villa tried Queen to
c2 not allowing the the character to
come with an attack on the Queen after
all the trades and now dubov awaits with
the capture wait with the capture on f3
and also with the recapture of the of
the e5 one and just plays a6 probably
with the idea that if white does push a
four it doesn't really come as a problem
to black you can always just allow
capture and trade so here we have Bishop
the f4 fiddler again plays with this
Bishop now putting it on this diagonal
maybe adding another defender but not
not all that important as the d5 pawn is
attacked four times
maybe clearing the path for the eve upon
but now
dubov doesn't allow it with Bishop
characters on f3 Bishop characters and
night to d4 now with an attack on the
Queen and the bishop on f3 Queen to e4
and now Bishop captures on e5 so what do
you do here with Bishop captures Queen
captures Queen captures and now Knight
captures on f3 with Czech pawn captures
and rook captures and d1 so do both
trades everything of the board rook
captures and now rook captures on e5 and
now we have this endgame where do both
is up upon it's a CC pawn but then again
a sailor has a doubled F pawn and when
you take everything into account its
it's a 42 advantage on the Queen side
and that's what's important here so if
you disregard the points on the King
side it's four to three in sailors favor
on the King side but the King's around
the King side so it's a much bigger
advantage having 42 on the Queen side
even though it's a CC pawn because it's
very very hard to deal with with threats
from blacks perspective for example you
could play some rook to d7 a very active
looking move but then rook e1 check
forces the King into this well hide out
he created here the the four points here
and then you can just go rookie do and
next you're gonna pick off this pawn for
example if rook captures on c7 now you
play rook captures on b2 now we have
three
one advantage on the queenside and white
doesn't really all why doesn't really
have all that much he can do against
just capturing yet another pawn and then
it's just three to zero advantage on the
queenside or if you try something like
rook to a seven
it's not a problem is you can just start
pushing your passport so it's it's a
very very easy win for black if
something like rook the d7 was play so
Spiller decides it's best to just
prevent rook to duty place came to f1
makes sense you want to bring the King
into the game and the dubov does the
same King g7 we have looked at d8 and
now comes looked sorry now comes a five
preparing before and also preparing to
create if before c3 is played then it
will create a very strong past C pawn
with f4 by swindler and now rook the c5
defending the c7 point also preparing to
push c3 King to e2 bringing the King in
third game and knocks e3 there's not all
that much you can do if you don't want
to allow capture so pawn captures pawn
captures and now comes a for trying to
create more weak points on the Queen
side and here Du Bois has do both can
play c6 just to defend the pawn here he
can play before he can advance the pond
here or he can just capture which he
does the the engine prefers c6 but this
this can't be bad you have three to zero
advantage and the Queen side so this is
what dubov goes for we have looked a d4
now filler wants to get his rook to a4
after the point is advanced to a3 he
wants to put his rook behind the past
pawn with a three by do both and now
rook to a4 we have looked the c2 check
and now you can either you can either
try and get your King over to the Queen
side to guard against those Queen side
points and then allow the capture of the
King side pawns but you're still not
gonna be able to capture the a trip on
because for example check just picks up
the rook not the greatest of plants so
after a king to e3 defending the DF two
points still we have a two now the point
is once again defended we have rook
captures on e5 eliminating one of the
points but now comes King to f6
dubov starts marching yes King
closer closer to the Turk wins I will g4
by swimmer King e6 with h4 by sailor and
now comes King to d6 and here
sailor is without without many useful
moves you can't go after this point you
can't go after the rook otherwise you
lose the the King side points you can't
threaten any points here any checks this
point is protected so there are no moves
that can actually create threats you
could play f3 just for example nuts to
make f3 a target but then black just
continues with his plan you want to get
all the way here put the rock back and
then start bringing the King well deeper
into the position you want to basically
get it over to b1 the threat and a1
Queen and after well the the rook checks
you from somewhere then you block check
with the rock that's basically the idea
but Federer decided to go for f5 and
here
dubov just playing G captures on f5 and
it was in this position that Peter
Svidler resigned the game so again one
of the right of the well fast Rapids
goes to Daniel dubov and the second game
were similar where duo had the white
pieces was drawn so with this game do
both eliminated Peter Svidler
from the Homburg fede grand prix 2019
and do both advances to the semifinals
were he will face young sheet of Duda
which is already being played but as as
we're a bit behind since we're
recovering the other tournament and I
had to go to Germany I haven't had the
opportunity to show these games and I
really enjoyed this one so I wanted to
show to the reason why Swilly resigned
this well he had some three minutes on
the clock here but there really isn't
all that much you can do after the point
is recaptured you cannot capture with
the rook you have to guard the the point
from queening so the idea is what we
already mentioned you will just bring
your king to b6 f 3 you make the f3 pawn
no longer a target king b6 once the rook
moves now you start advancing the King
all the way to b1 and the there aren't
all that many great plans here for
example this rook will start checking
you if you go for the B file but it's
not a problem since you can always just
you know dodge
checks and then once you reach b1 you
will just cover with the rock ruby - and
then you will promote this point or you
can start marching with the White King
but then just look if - and then you're
gonna pick up all the kings side points
and you're gonna give up this pawn but
you're gonna grab all these guys and
it's there's no counter play here if
King back the e3 then look H do you go
after the h4 point if Brooke the a fork
to guard the pond then you move the King
back in b5 rookie 7 you're gonna push c5
now you're gonna start pushing the C
pawn as well and white has no contra
blue here
so of course we'll go knows this and
after G CalPERS on f5 he resigned the
game and a very nice victory for Daniel
dubov who as our red mention advances to
the semi-final where he will face a poly
grandmaster young feast of Duda so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
or we have requested it in the comments
so there it is I really enjoyed it as
well so thank you for that I would like
to thank the DA regal in it John Wensley
ya Mario Gouda Ryan Farooq and Timofey
votes keen for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it
and as you know you probably realize the
code above the board and why it's there
but the meaning of the code above the
board is actually twofold for this video
so you can also try to guess why is that
in the comment section so as usual you
can check to my previous videos here I
think of for watching and I will see you
soon continuing the coverage of the Fida
grand prix checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and of course preparing our
next big saga thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day